COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some urban developers
get their sensors straight.
Will we be able to
find parking in time?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Like most IoT
companies, Urban IoT
makes their money
deploying hordes
of sensors in an urban area
that monitor everything
from noise, temperature, and
humidity, which of course means
that the majority of their
data that they collect
from those devices consists
of timestamps and simple
floating point numbers,
the volume of which
quickly started showing
a problem with Datastore
performance.
See, Cloud Datastore is built
on top of Bigtable, and thus,
is subject to its
performance characteristics.
Bigtable scales by sharding rows
into separate tablets, which
are basically a contiguous
unit of storage.
And when a tablet experiences
a high write rate,
the tablet will split, allowing
it to scale even further.
The important point
here is this-- rows
in the tablet are
ordered such that it
helps distribute the workload
amongst multiple tablets.
They do this by sorting the rows
lexicographically by their key.
And as long as the keys
are randomly distributed,
this sorting works pretty fine.
However, if your keys are
lexicographically close,
then your performance
starts to suffer,
as your operations can be
isolated into a small update
window, which, lo and behold,
was exactly what Urban IoT was
doing.
Turns out their
federation of IoT devices
were pushing sensor
readings into Datastore
and using the timestamp
as the key for the entity
so they could easily fetch
and display the results later.
Timestamps, of course, are a
monotonically increasing value,
which is being used as an
index property, which led right
into the hop spotting scenario
that we were worried about.
Now here's the really
interesting part.
This behavior was really
hard to repo on our side.
I mean, we set up a 250 QPS
load test creating entities
with keys that are timestamps
over a 20-minute window
and didn't see anything.
Datastore did an amazing job at
absorbing that level of work,
no problems whatsoever.
In order to actually
see this behavior,
we had to jack the QPS up
to 750 and let the test
run for over an hour.
You can see that over time
it takes a little longer
to handle the same operations.
For Urban IoT, the least
invasive fix for this problem
was to append a random prefix
to their timestamps, which
caused some headaches in
their dashboard for fetching,
but also allowed their
performance to land back
in the non-hot-spotted area.
Now I just want to
highlight something again.
This is not a standard,
run-of-the-mill performance
issue.
It took a couple of days of
really hammering on Datastore
to get our tests to behave the
way that Urban IoT was seeing
in the wild.
And my guess is
that unless your use
case is very similar
to theirs, chances
are you won't run into it.
So if you'd like ideas on where
to spend your time instead,
make sure you check out the rest
of the Cloud Performance Atlas
content.
Because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]